mr dropping just dropping
dropping
mr talking
dropping
chocolate
chopping
knocking chestnuts
knocking dressings
[Music]
[Music]
my own money
[Music]
this week in feminism
[Music]
i mean yeah i hit him like really hard
but
he wasn't supposed to do anything about
it he went somewhere
louder with crowder is brought to you in
part by production.com
you don't have to be a freeloader your
whole life the good news is that you can
support this show and the fight by
buying some really cool clues
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
that's a nice uh that's a nice thing
was
my headphones here as i do this because
i i was going around in here earlier and
i uh by the way hi uh steven crowder
this is my pimple i brought it with me
oh i couldn't even see it point it out
you can't even see it angela help show
me how dying makeup but yeah it's look
it's it's smiling at me
um
is it bring your pimple to work day yes
it is okay
it wanted to observe what i do so that
it can slowly eat its host you know that
there's you know there's a lot of like
poppers out there right now that want
you to uh yeah i'm not kidding that side
channel asian doctor with a little metal
tool that is so weird come on this is
not age appropriate for youtube it is a
senior picture pimple though yes
and i made the mistake of trying to
squeeze it and just made it worse so i
apologize to everyone that you have to
see this uh might i recommend the audio
version
today today
of course anywhere anywhere you can
bring it up this is a good time a good
time as any to plug it apple android
spotify
anywhere podcasts are sold or downloaded
for free all over the place um look we
have a lot to talk uh about today and
i'm going to just state on the outside i
think it's time to disband the nba
disband the fbi and the nba and the nih
yes and uh well all the acronyms get rid
of the wnba
it's time to take out take out the hair
bands and let them see what happens i
mean
wnba is working on it themselves nwa can
stay they can stick it's hard to say i
like nwa if i got to say it yeah yeah
that's true
don't spell it out did i ruin it already
no right no no no no
i was sitting there thinking yeah what
do we do
what do i do in naming my favorite
richard pryor albums i have no idea look
it is time i do want to i'm going to get
to this in a bit so we're going to sort
of
build a case here you know you saw that
the fbi raided james o'keefe you've seen
what's now happened with the steele
dossier the russian trump colu the
russia trump collusion hoax there have
now been arrests we know that the fbi
has been complicit and the biggest story
to come out of the kyle rittenhouse
trial
is something that many people aren't
talking about and to me was absolutely
terrifying
and we need to take a step back and it
involves the fbi i obviously uh i think
a lot of conservatives out there want to
support people who are out there
protecting this country and sometimes
kind of toss intelligence agencies into
that same uh into that same pot and it's
not really the case we are at a point
where the fbi is so selective in their
prosecution the law is not applied
equally that i think it's beyond repair
uh you guys can let me know what you
think we're going to talk about that but
before i move on
it is time to say hi to gerald a how are
you i am well sir how are you i'm okay
you have a good weekend yeah except for
this throbbing thing oh wow well yeah
this this one's dropping from the show
there yeah
garrett quarterback was late to the
punch to cut to it i was pointing oh
okay i know it's there
corner how are you sir i am doing good
yeah well you don't get pimples but you
don't get razor bumps that's true i've
seen that in the aisles
it's bump bump away but i read it like
this bump away oh geez and that's fine
november 11th he's going to be at the
catillion in wichita kansas
it's this thursday get tickets wichita
kansas yeah this thursday uh and the
thing about the cotillion is it is in
his basement yes well it'll change fine
print we also going to be talking about
michigan and menstruating people mm-hmm
uh
you're talking about aoc and by the way
listen i want to let you guys know this
is very important
because we're going to talk about how
some of our content from last week on
the right house trial has now been age
restricted oh my gosh spoiler alert the
exact same footage we had used which
resulted in our restriction is still up
from the new york times and several
other channels so if this happens to
disappear we never know when the live
stream will be bumped off
just know the stream is still going on
you can join mug club or if you want the
free [ __ ] you can still go over to
rumble the show is still on monday
through thursday at 10 a.m eastern it
just may not be on youtube forever i
just want you to know that so you don't
wonder where we yeah i don't want you to
sit there when i'm wondering where
little crowd i ran off to
so uh before we move on here let's uh
talk about this aoc had uh her thoughts
uh
she stuck her uh she took her or in dave
ooh yeah yeah she stuck her oren
but she i don't know why she had an aura
in her tesla well no idea i don't know
what that's totally impractical at that
point it almost just creates drag it's
true
but uh aoc stuck her or in on the uh
virginia failure she's giving out advice
and uh it's uh this time not the best
way to shoot an irish karbala on the
election front i actually think we have
good news as well we know that virginia
was a huge bummer
and honestly if anything
i think that the results show the limits
of trying to run a fully 100
super moderated campaign that does not
excite
speak to or energize a progressive base
and frankly we weren't even really
invited
to contribute on that race well she's
like hooper humperding she's never
invited no that's right it was uh it was
by design yes they didn't want you at
the party by the way because
leaving one star yes
he's just right he's an iranian
character like [ __ ] shut up you'll
never stop i always want to start you
always give me babe shut up stop talking
you always talk i drive you all the time
you never stop talking
your voice is painful
i have a i have a pressure cooker in
back in the back of nails you shut up oh
geez
she's just so interesting yeah no she's
right though it was too moderate yes
please continue please this is just kind
of like with the prosecution in the
written house trial people are saying
why isn't the defense no no no
let them shoot themselves in the foot
yes let aoc have influence upon her
party please yeah the republican party's
response is
please continue yes
just
put her videos up on a big screen guys i
really think you should listen to aoc i
mean really yeah and i think when in
doubt just accuse more voters of being
racist especially suburban white moms it
works works like a charm every time i
shouldn't even be saying this and all
the black i shouldn't be giving away all
our secrets i don't even know what i'm
thinking i mean no no i shouldn't be
telling you she's right you should accu
you should listen to aoc and accuse all
voters of being racist and then uh just
tell them that critical race theory
doesn't exist but you know what that's
all i'm gonna say
no more pointers from me
it just makes common sense unless you
sign up for my mailing list then it's
you know i'm going to dick morris said
i'm going to give up my tips oh jeez
so
election 911 is this your thing for
crying out loud keep in mind too that
with the left these were not moderate
candidates and by the way some people
were trying to give me flak and you're
kind of right i said they voted out
governor blackface i know he had served
his full terms but obviously when you're
talking about his democratic hair
apparent right they voted against it in
principle i just want to make sure that
i clarify that i know how terms work not
sure how blackface works apparently when
a canadian prime minister whose liberal
does it nine times
and the governor of virginia does it
repeatedly it's not a problem brought to
you by kiwi yeah it's totally acceptable
in canada actually yes it is well yeah
it's a different thing yeah and virginia
apparently yeah i mean that made sense i
can't keep track of the rules anymore
and on the view so we just do it here
um
my question before i move on here why do
you think the fbi was flying a drone and
or plane
over kenosha
right as kyle was being attacked yeah
and i want to back up to that because i
have a bunch of other information to
kind of deliver but it's easy to get
lost in the shuffle whereas really the
reaction should be wait
wait wait
shift zoom
the fbi had a drone above kenosha yeah
that's exactly what the reaction should
be they just skim past it like oh yeah
by the way the fbi footage they lost
some of those footages where everyone's
going okay so they lost some of that
footage wait what
the fbi had a drone or plane over
kenosha while the riots were burning how
many lives did they save by the way
do they well you know i'll get to in a
second before that let me go to governor
uh governor whitmer oh boy she's still a
governor she is sadly
she is until she she gets hit by a house
and her feet curl up unless the fbi has
something to say about it so uh over the
weekend she announced and i'm not even
against this to be clear i'm not against
somebody appealing the tampon tax that's
something they're going to do because
they claim it's a necessity yeah just to
be clear i get it i think this is
something that isn't all that big of a
deal it's it's how they decided to word
this
bill and how they decided to word the
praise of this bill that should give
everyone who has who's taken biology 101
you know in junior high yeah pause see
if you can spot it a trip to the
pharmacy won't cost as much anymore for
essential items like tampons and pads
after governor whitmer signed a
bipartisan bill ending the so-called
tampon tax i never dreamed number one
we'd get it done number two would take
this long to get it done from eddie
murphy's raw i'd be the one who gets to
sign this bill into one of michael
jackson's really happy about that
this is a step toward empowering and
supporting women in this economy and and
menstruating michiganders
now i know what you're thinking well
that was a slip of the tongue because
she said women at some point
menstruating michiganders no no let me
read a statement here she also said this
is primarily for me and for i think most
of the people that have been supporting
the change in this law about fairness
about ensuring that people who
menstruate are not punished for that
biological activity i repeat
people who menstruate are not punished
for that biological activity well hold
on a second
is it people who menstruate
or is it biological activity
which is it is it people who menstruate
which includes the glorified halloween
mask with the pump that would bleed you
just knew those kids were rich because
they're like 55
right right
that bleeds only it's your you know
punani
or is it biological activity meaning
only women who can biologically
menstruate this is the issue here they
just kind of they just keep layering it
on menstruating michiganders people who
menstruate
this would have been considered a straw
man not too long ago and in fairness her
husband hopes this will uh actually
create a domino effect um and remove the
tax on other feminine products so he's
yeah well you know oh geez that's a high
product i'm about to
i'm shocked that this is coming from the
party of science shocked i tell you by
the way she also said something in the
very beginning that was contradictory
number one i'm surprised that we were
able to get this done and number two i'm
surprised it took so long yeah did
anybody else catch that it's like i
guess well i was kind of busy killing
your girl yeah i was surprised that it
ever happened yeah and i was surprised
that it took this long oh i wasn't
surprised i definitely killed your
grandma well that's true as you know i
am stretching and i spent a lot of money
on champions yes i gotta tell you it is
quite a bunch sometimes i just use a
turkey leg from a
honestly
renaissance
absolutely true sometimes you do a
turkey leg and now you got always pads
with that with uh wings and you know
optional heated uh heated seats for
crying out loud back i would just you
know i just tie a rabbit skin with some
sanu yeah that's what i
it's very very broken in there you know
but back then
i'd like a good carpet square but you
know what that's back then
you didn't see
periods from guys so every the rules are
changing all around you know rabbit
skins guys get guys menstruating too you
know you got to get with the times
yeah i asked my doctor i said my
husband's uh penis is menstruating yeah
and he says that's not what that is
oh and i i said are you sure and she
said yeah yeah yeah she said she said
well maybe if you stop whacking it with
a mallet
[Laughter]
man alice cooper has to change his song
though
only women and men bleed
only penises bleed only penis is
bleeding
whatever you want bleeds
whatever you and that's what they want
think about this there will be think
about this for a second there will be
people outraged
across the mitten state
because they yearn and i wish i wanted
anything as badly as these biological
men want to have periods think about
that they have actually intimidated the
governor of michigan enough to say
menstruating michiganders people who
menstruate now what's the problem with
that when they try to tell it was the
name of my football team right yes
mine was mine was the guppies oh well
sorry it was the menstruating guppies
which isn't even accurate yes get your
aquatic biology correct mine was the
bleeding blue balls yes oh geez
the thing is really when you think about
think about this for a second honestly i
can't they're that offended and they and
they'll tell you that critical race
theory is not a thing well technically
right now she'll say i never we're not
teaching in schools that men get periods
no no you say menstruating people say
that's how it starts just like they say
well critical race theory is well no
one's saying it's a course
what they're saying is critical race
theory is now an english class it's in
biology class yeah it's in history class
in college it's a course it's a set of
guidelines
for every part of the curriculum and it
starts with
people who menstruate we need to and
this is the problem with big tech right
where they said well you can't say you
can't say that because you're you're
actually you're insulting someone's
immutable characteristic first off it's
not immutable a man can hit mute on his
fake period
[Laughter]
it starts from authoritative sources and
everyone has to accept it as though it's
normal yes yes it is completely normal
for men to have periods i stand
corrected how do you did he cram that
into history though you're like right
here is where john wilkes booth makes
lincoln's head menstruate
right here's jfk he menstruates twice in
this limo right jeez back
ronald reagan they tried to make a men
straight but tesla [ __ ] just decided he
wouldn't they didn't no no he didn't
menstruate i love how they kind of
matter of fact his uh his dick grew
three sizes that day i don't know how it
and jody foster decided to go with women
that men straight because of john
hinckley and of course she's a sexist ah
right we're about to say that i was
gonna say they kind of box themselves
into a corner because biological women
would stop it biological women would
have been fine right but it's like no
well you can't say that it's like how
hell what do we say i don't know
menstruating people that sounds
reasonable right no to no one doesn't
sound made up well i think it's good
that they want to put the men into men
straight yes
[Music]
that's how they're going to teach the
kids they have you know snoop the
wrapping dog like yo i put the men back
in men straight
i'm snoop the menstruating dog and i'm
here to say i'm bleeding from my cooch
every day hey kids
my wife fur has gone away
i say no to drugs i like how they save
what is the how much money are you
saving the average person here
36 cents a month
it's yeah they act like it's such an
amazing they said 4 800 over the course
of a year over the course of a lifetime
oh wait wait wait hold on what
i don't know
i don't know the women they picked in
that sample study yeah did they look
like the elevator from the shining yes
yeah that's like the sample i don't like
yeah
group a and the control group is red rum
what the hell is going on
we're gonna need some paper towels uh
well i guess we put in the budget some
tricycles i don't know why they were
paying for tricycles in the study
well twins i think you know this one
okay so by the way uh follow us on
instagram we're gonna take your live
chats later and play age restricted or
not on mug club today big ass fun game
that we could never play on youtube
never today is a perfect guesses big and
there's big no there's big ass well
they're there no
no no i was the devil's advocate i don't
know don't your sister look good yeah
jesus yeah
now let's talk about how big bird got
not
myocarditis
so over the weekend big bird revealed
that he got vaccinated tweeting oh
whoopee dude i got the coven 19 vaccine
today my wing is feeling a little sore
but i'll give my body an extra
protective boost that keeps me and
others healthy miss erica hill even said
i've been getting vaccines since i was a
little bird i had no idea now
unfortunately and i understand the
sentiment i don't have anything against
it but it resulted in a newly mutated
highly communicable
form of bird flu oh no and required big
birds immediate execution we go now live
to the proceedings i've never been in a
hospital before
there's no reason to be scared come with
me so i can examine you and we can start
to make you feel better can i ask you a
few questions uh
okay maria it's all right big bird i'll
be right here
[Music]
[Laughter]
hey don't laugh it's horrible
so sad
see what waits did he do to oscar the
grouch
gone too soon
he threw a grenade in his trash can and
locked all this
yeah what's the saddest part is big
bird's very tall and you know that took
a while
those screams went on forever at least
start with my head
why did you start with my legs
i have to feel all of this
snuffle up i guess is going to him
before and he's like
here take this no
i have to keep my wits about me
i'm almost like now i'm going to
pedophile everyone
elmo did one too as they're killing it
vaccinated he did he got vaccinated yeah
oh he's used to jabbing kids does
anybody know that these are felt yeah
you're just wasting vaccines yeah and
they're tweeting on a platform and
there's no children who are you
and big bird in his final words cried
out
letter
all right close enough
big bird what is he i don't even know i
don't know what kind of bird he's
supposed to be like a mutant he's a
mutant yeah exactly he's eight feet tall
i never see nothing like that no think
about this for a second birds they also
they eat like worms and stuff you know
birds are predators those kids aren't
safe no
is she that tall you think birds like
there's no way sesame street could be
real because we wouldn't get along with
them no we wouldn't of course they
wouldn't be able to drink at the same
fountains now grover all blue wow come
on not to mention they make him put on
his [ __ ] leather helmet
rover no you need to be institutional
cookie monster you just make them
vegetable monster yeah well how creepy
was that oh yeah
nobody loves carrots that much well
they're having sex with them
that doesn't that's elmo
prolapse soap
vaccine mandates sphincter
the vaccine mandate has now been halted
this is just kind of a fun win uh over
the weekend the fifth circuit court of
appeals halted biden's mandate on
companies over you know this is one on
companies pretty good over 100 employees
this resulted from lawsuits coming from
the great states of texas and florida um
louisiana jumped in there too i was a
little surprised to see them at the game
really i think so that's right yeah well
you know these these rules don't tend to
hold up in court they do not so this is
the pro this is also though what biden
had said remember with the rent
extension he said it's probably
unconstitutional but we're going to do
it anyway and then eventually the courts
will strike it down but that'll you know
give people six more months of not
paying rent to screw the landlords
that's what you'd love to hear from your
president three days
right this might be unconstitutional
fifth circuit court of appeals not the
other ones that are idiots to step in
and say no we have to stop this by the
way you said it doesn't hold up yeah
five of the last six emergency
authorizations kind of like this uh have
not held up in court well five of the
last six that's that's a pretty bad well
they didn't have to deal with the full
ferocity of osha by god let me let me
give you some context the last one that
uh got challenged uh asbestos asbestos
was allowed oh wow
look at that look at that asbestos
survived the challenge she's like oh
geez wait what do you mean it's best to
survive the challenge meaning so the the
state of the mandate to not use asbestos
yeah well they were the osha was
mandating something on asbestos the
states challenged and the court said no
uh oh [ __ ] you can't make
asbestos and the states won so the state
said we demand being able to are you
using asbestos they probably didn't use
those words yeah well
houses were already built well you know
that's true what are you gonna do tear
them down yeah you gotta get hospitals
you know how expensive that pink
insulating foam is what's up i mean come
on this is this stuff doesn't burn
something it's more of a try it's more
of a mercury lead as best as try blend
really geez they say there's particles
in the air i don't see them no no i
don't see them it can't be possible my
family made a lot of money off asbestos
yeah well it's asbestos that feeds you
it's the that's just the clothes you so
now it's gone now let's move on here to
the fbi so i have a few things that i
want to tie in here so i want you guys
to to kind of understand the through
line and you know comment below before
uh those who aren't watching uh live or
watching the archive
if you think we should disband the fbi
and then i'll i'll present my case to
you here
because a lot happened here this last
week yeah that involves the fbi and more
importantly i was going back through the
written house trial last week which is
it's interesting by the way what the
media chooses not to cover
they choose not to cover the written
house trial because there's no way that
this kid looks they did like day one but
then they they cut it off it got real it
wasn't all really really bad very
quickly
so
first you know the the steele dossier
the russia collusion yeah right this was
something that keep in mind was paid for
by hillary clinton operatives the
democratic nation democratic national
committee and the fbi was complicit
saying there was evidence for it
remember they were on air saying this we
have a we have it on good authority that
this is authentic okay so last week igor
denchenko was indicted as part of the
durham investigation
charged with five counts of lying to the
fbi by the sources for again the bogus
steel dossier um keep in mind this is
you know using information from this guy
this is how christopher steele compiled
that fusion gps that that basically
remember all the information about the
donald trump russia collusion hoax
stemmed from this dossier fusion gps the
company steele dossier is what it was
entirely fake
now arrests are starting to come down
only because it is
so undeniable that something has to be
done but the media echoed it for years
and of course this resulted in
prosecution of donald trump and of a lot
of his uh a lot of his uh not only
employees but colleagues not a wasted
time and the fbi
was backing it the fbi had people making
public statements that's what's so
concerning and of course do you think
what this guy lied to the fbi well the
fbi's been caught lying about it
themselves so at what point what point
does it matter if one guy lied to the
fbi he's just lying to another liar
right and by the way just remember day
one of him being in office he's a
russian mole he's a russian spy he's
influenced by the kremlin he can't
possibly stand up to putin because he's
too close to him oh my god he had a
private meeting with putin they must
have been hatching their plans together
that was what we had on a drip from cnn
msnbc abc everybody covering it
and this was easily disproven i mean
very quickly very quick proven but they
just kept running with the lie because
nobody would call them out right and it
was it was one of those things that
did a lot of damage it did did a lot of
damage look there's absolutely more
evidence of course that there was
collusion
from the hillary clinton campaign in the
2016 election that there was there was
hackery afoot
oh there's a better word for that but we
can't say it on air
that there are elections shenanigans of
15. in 2016
uh from hillary clinton than donald
trump with russia yeah
why because they paid for they paid for
this
is a clinton campaign paid for this
dossier whatever you can get keep in
mind at the same time at the same time
if i didn't do anything about hillary
clinton acid washing her hard drives and
her email is gone so in other words when
there's something that is admittedly
a crime that's been committed by the
clintons admittedly like well okay at
the very least we got rid of those
emails right you're not allowed to do
that you're not allowed a lot to do that
with a government computer
as far as ditchy acid washes the hard
drives to what extent
that's conjecture but admittedly it's
already enough of a crime this ah you
know what it doesn't matter at this
point didn't win who cares well hold on
a second you cared enough
to continue
prosecuting to continue serving warrants
to continue intimidating based on
something that was entirely false
this is you you have to we're going to
continue through this kind of trail of
thought you either have to believe that
the fbi is so incompetent that it is of
no use meaning they had no ability to
vet the steele dossier meaning they
didn't watch this show
or
they are dishonest
but there is no door number three at
this point yeah and then we had the text
messages from those two fbi agents back
and forth about how we're not going to
let this happen donald trump won't be
president right right insinuating that
that was going to be the case but this
was also used as a pretext for further
investigations like you said
investigations that would have never
happened otherwise right right this
opened the door for them to go kind of
pilfering through donald trump's
associates trying to find something on
someone right now some of them maybe
some shady characters were in there and
he should have distanced himself he did
like manafort itself later on yeah he
did right but at the same time this
should have never happened no it's not
how this works no well here we go now
this goes to another point uh over the
weekend james o'keefe's home was raided
oh no for the alleged and when i say
alleged i mean absolutely otherwise why
would his home be raided well did he
have illegal weapons or something really
dangerous
he had copy he had criterion copies of
lethal weapon one two and three oh not a
fan of four he i rate his house for that
i didn't think it was bad chris rock and
jet league my point
well for four i think you should do a
little time yeah
come on we're not talking about you know
transformers for well my point is you
should be executed whatever his crimes
yes but whatever his crimes there is a
legal process for executing someone for
maintaining
a copy of lethal weapon for yes the
criterion collection yes the criterion
collection but the point is due process
fine innocent until proven shitty
so over the weekend james o'keefe's home
was rated for the alleged absolutely
diary of ashley biden joe biden's
daughter here's a clip from james i woke
to the news that apartments and homes of
project veritas journalists or former
journalists had been raided by fbi
agents it appears the southern district
of new york now has journalists in their
sites for the supposed crime of doing
their jobs lawfully and honestly or at
least this journalist late last year we
were approached by tipsters claiming
that a copy of ashley biden's diary we
had never met or heard of the tipsters
we took steps to corroborate the
authenticity of the diary
at the end of the day we made the
ethical decision that because in part we
could not determine if the diary was
real we never published it now ms
biden's father's department of justice
specifically the united states
attorney's office for the southern
district of new york appears to be
investigating the situation
claiming the diary was stolen okay so
now they're claiming that in other words
one agent said that that diary was
stolen
i mean fake
by the way they raided his house they
were incredibly confused they just are
like ashley's chaps and we have 20
single pit with single gloves
not pears who does that he has an entire
green screen for michael jackson
parodies what is this big fan i thought
we were going to the journalists house
he's just making his own notes with a
pen that has a big heart on the end of
it
keep in mind
just do people remember they're going
after for ashley biden's diary okay
trump's tax returns a diary
put this in context if you went to the
local police or you called the fbi and
said my diary's missing
crazy on line 12 right there
let me share anne frank no one cares
about diary
even stevens what is this zen frank i
would just a ghost but
the point is they would say crazy on
line 12. they would say let me get this
straight ma'am you want me
to send an agent
to go look for your diary several just
to check on it it says i like brandon
listen several places
but my point is there is actually some
protection for tax returns there should
be donald trump's tax returns that were
obtained but was it new york times or
washington post i can't remember i
thought it was time shitty birds of a
feather legitimate but the point is any
fbi agent sent to that no anything but
this is a diary which is not legally
protected if it was lost just like hunt
hunter biden keep in mind some people
still believe that his laptop was stolen
he returned it to geek squad and was too
high to remember to pick it up
just
it's not only state law it's geek
squad's policy i know it's not a branded
geek squad but it's a computer repair
shop they say if you don't return it or
if you don't return to pick it up within
90 days and it doesn't doesn't have
exceptions for crack cocaine as far as i
read from this policy that then it is uh
it is basically they're probably
available
well at least he wasn't pawning it like
some scumbag right well by the way just
to be clear the the new york times story
totally fine on twitter uh even though
that's illegal the the story about
hunter biden totally not fine on twitter
from the new york post well also ashley
biden i've noticed this is throttled
here so i want to be clear with you we
cannot confirm the authenticity of the
diary right
any more than the fbi just any more than
the fbi just did you don't raid a house
you don't rate a house for a stolen
diary you don't rate it for dogs at
poker hanging on right now exactly
that's not going to happen it's like ah
we have a warrant for a dog calendar
we're particularly concerned about
september with labrador retrievers
they're in the back of what appears to
be a hayride
they're so cute
if we let you have this then we'd have
to let everybody have this would you let
us in please so october one is wearing a
witch's castle yes it's adorable and if
you look there that pumpkin is actually
a wiener dog oh
it is march fresh lies eating a beagle's
face that's the main one we're concerned
about arch you don't want to that was
not made for uh public print yes that
was more personal that was southeast
that's what we call it here these are
technical terms you need to concern
yourself with
so let me be clear about the diary i
have read it some people have said how
did you read it uh because it has been
publicly leaked everywhere yeah it's on
the internet and whether it's i do think
it's true
i'll tell you why okay
so it includes a few things in there
that are disconcerting first off she
seems like she's a sex addict because
she says she's a sex addict she's
obviously a drug addict she's obviously
someone who has been damaged in her life
she obviously resents her father a whole
lot seems like she was molested as a
child we do not know by whom just to be
clear this is the exact girl i would hit
on yes
maybe like that is available and she
wrote this i remember having sex with
friends at a young age
showers with my dad and in parentheses
probably not appropriate what thanks for
adding that
um was it i don't know if they brought
it up i asked him to bring it up uh
tokono and make sure we get it from the
control room hunter biden he was sexting
with his niece if i'm not mistaken and
then he had a picture with an underage
girl who was not his niece but he was
definitely sexting with his niece she's
showering i mean incest just seems to
run in the biden family there were feet
involved i thought it is just running in
the biden family you got that
in the show okay allegedly so uh she
also wrote about feeling self-righteous
during the hunter halle fiasco and keep
in mind hallie is beau's wife
who uh okay look hunter was let me be
really clear about this and this is
corroborated in this diary hunter biden
banged his brother's
widow
then banged her sister
wow and then sex at least i don't know
when if this happened congruently
sexted his niece and there are pictures
of him uh you know uh with underage
girls smoking crack and throwing a gun
in a dumpster by a school correct any
face time with biden saying that he uh
or no no sorry he texted biden that he
faced time with a 14 year old girl while
naked and smoking crack
winner really
this is a really screwed up family like
i don't want to just judge on it but
come on at a certain point you say none
of you and here's one thing this is me
making an inference
every single one of biden's children
is a drug addicted compulsive lying
cheating
[ __ ] or man [ __ ] every single one at a
certain point you go okay what what
happened there from the top down every
single one and i mean started from a
very very young age having problems
having
emotional issues having relationship
issues having substance abuse issues
having
incestuous issues yeah so a quick
question when did bo
pass away that was
later on right uh it was roughly before
hunter banged his well no i believe
that's the timeline well i was wondering
i was like okay well a tragic event in a
family can sometimes you know spin
people out but it seems like all this
was going on prior to beau's day well
it's weird if it spun him out to bang
his brother's wife and then bang her
sister yeah sometimes that's a lot of
spinning i remember when i lost my aunt
and i started banging my cousin i was
not saying yeah yeah
i remember when my grandmother died and
i started uh you know i started banging
his cousin yeah smoking crack and
yeah bow down spinning out like the
tilta world okay so beau died in 2015.
yeah so that's that's a different okay
what did he have i was trying to look
for like the common thing other than
just the biden family but that looks
like it's a biden family
all right uh this is this is creepy it
really is creepy
i mean it's look i get the drug
addiction and stuff i can relate yeah
but smoking cheese yeah well i've never
smoked nobody i know has ever smoked
here's an issue
because you've had addiction right
you've talked about it openly
at some point someone's sat you down and
obviously said okay you need to make a
change and you need to ultimately be
self-accountable sometimes roomful right
but hunter biden has never had that
well hunter biden is still st was still
lying about it and
getting speaking fees for talking about
becoming so after he was still on drugs
just to be clear he has continually lied
about it and he hasn't had a father
who's tried to hold him accountable if
you look at ashley biden and you read in
her diary she's not talking about a
father who's trying to help her she's
talking about a father who's a political
climber and she really resents him she
thinks that he's emotionally
manipulative she thinks that he's
uncaring she thinks he's unsympathetic
so the point is yes you can have a
substance abuse problem but these people
have had lifetime substance and sex
abuse problems and it doesn't seem
according to the diaries and according
to hunter biden's laptop like the
parents were ever interested in helping
well i don't think it seemed that the
parents ever really cared i mean with
hunter it seems that he actually he
seems to have a relationship with hunter
not with ashley that's at least how it
seems whenever you didn't even know
ashley was a thing yeah
no daughter there really is no
connection there and i think it's
because
he glorifies his father where she is
obviously broken by him at least from
what you can tell but yeah there is a
point he may have had people sit him
down he's i'm sure he's had
interventions and stuff like that he's
just he's never done anything about it
because it seems every time i see him
interviewed he seems
very high right well barisma looked at
that resume and met with hunter and said
yes he does need to sit down on our
board yeah right let's pay him lots and
lots of money to sit on our board and
make decisions for our company because
he alone
only actions
are worth ever they only ever had him at
one board meeting because then he lit up
a bowl rich
yeah
i think we should fail
talking about this they started smoking
a glass dick and they're like that is a
captain of industry yes
are you sexting in the board meeting yes
right did you uh put your shirt on we
just replaced his crack rock with
himalayan pink salt
i think it's good enough
it works
by the way i have these pictures of my
sister in the shower that's dead
[Laughter]
maybe inappropriate maybe what pieces of
absolute garbage well it's just i'm
tired of it's a waste of taxpayers money
to bang down a door and get evidence
well it's weaponized it's a waste of
someone's money where they're saying oh
the diary might be stolen which is them
acknowledging that it's an authentic
diary right yeah how about hey do you
have a valid warrant for underage sex
crimes with hunter biden
underage sex crimes by the way no one
denies it
no one denies the authenticity of it
right except for you know twitter and
facebook they tried to then they said we
made they even said we made a mistake
which is oop sorry too late they blocked
the story from the new york post
remember that no one denies the
authenticity at the very least if he's
not just
sexting underage girls there are
pictures of him with underage kids and
doing drugs hunter biden
you can't get a warrant for that but you
get a warrant on james o'keefe who puts
on silly suits and catches politicians
and pharmaceutical companies saying
illegal [ __ ]
well what's the purpose of retrieving
the diary
other than to protect
send a message that don't get too close
don't get too close to the target that's
really what it is and the fbi when they
heard that when the department of
justice came to them and said do this
they should have said no yeah they
should have said absolutely you know
what hell no there's no way on earth we
are going to do this if the fbi were
sodom and gomorrah
and god were like all right i'll make an
obsession
like wait lord what if we can find five
good there aren't it's done
he would just light it ablaze he would
turn it into salt just it is that bad i
don't know that there's anyone as far as
the desks jockeys left i'm not talking
about police out in the field right desk
jockeys the fbi cia they have and think
about this for a second we're going to
go on here to cal written house
who do you think is most likely to want
to procure
effectively a lifetime position
at a government bureaucracy government
bureaucracy i swallowed wrong yeah
but think about this for a second the
federal bureau of investigation yes
fauci
uh he's never he hasn't held private
office yeah really in his in his adult
life at this point right think about
this the fbi who do you think is going
to be easiest to appoint these missions
of course it's not people who say hey i
believe in a limited government i
believe in term limits yeah i believe
the government should be for the people
by the people representative of the
people i have a problem with career
politicians the left they go to college
and study political science because they
want to be not only career politicians
but career appointees the point is if
you have people who are looking to be
career appointees it's really easy to
chip away at any of these arms of the
federal government and ensure that at
some point
cumulatively oh the fbi's entirely left
cumulatively okay all the cia is
entirely left look at how woke
all of it is at this point look at
what's happening with the military
first female admiral it said to said
hideous fat prick rachel levine
all right speaking of oh here's
something there's something uh funny
going on too in the uh
in the written house trial uh which clip
is this i'm about to show this is the
fbi footage okay so uh you can just play
it and i'll talk over it so uh that way
okay bring in the volume on it yeah so
keep in mind this is footage that you
see in there in black and white from the
fbi okay
that's fbi footage all right
now you see how it's edited and it's
choppy
there is a full hd file that is not
edited that's very very low res
the fbi says they lost it
just to be clear misplaced fbi they
never provided it to the defense they
said
uh we don't have it anymore now now look
before i get to this i'm gonna okay so
the fbi had that footage it's edited
they have hd footage you're saying and
they lost it i don't hold on no no wait
back up back up back up back up
we just walked past the fbi had drones
or planes above kenosha wisconsin
what yeah and we're only finding out
about that [ __ ]
from some grainy edited video at trial
where the fbi
selectively withheld evidence this is my
question
were they in kenosha the night before
when the city was ablaze hey does the
fbi have planes and or drone footage
from all of the riots over the course of
that summer with thousands of casualties
and arrests and billions of dollars in
damages if they had these surveillance
drones or planes i don't want to
misspeak and be caught on that because
it depends on which source you use
how many lives did they save if they
didn't do that it's almost like the fbi
serves no purpose so before we go down
the trail of how the fbi is not
providing this evidence to the defense
saying they lost it
this isn't front page everywhere the fbi
had footage of kenosha
more they had footage entire of the kyle
written house shooting and them chasing
kyle and it was congruent with footage
showing these people threatening to kill
kyle and they did not make this publicly
available and they're still they're not
making the high res
what are we missing yeah i don't
understand and if they had it throughout
the summer of love shouldn't they be
using it the same way they've put it
together here spliced it together with
other video from the scenes to make sure
that perpetrators people who tried to
that might be someone by the way they
did give the raw that that footage it
wasn't spliced together from the fbi no
meaning so the fbi was that top part and
they were basically just putting it
together so you can see on the ground
and above so you could see the full shot
i'm like okay well that's fantastic you
remember the police officer in chicago
that was being dragged from the police
line and the fellow officers were
desperately trying to keep her back
maybe you could use it to identify that
person and put them in jail maybe some
of those things could be done who shot
david doran so brandt what who shot
david dorn that'd be a good use of that
footage yeah yeah so brendan and our
researchers they just pulled a clip from
the trial today they're actually talking
about this right now and the prosecutor
basically tried to characterize it as
oh the fbi had it then then they lost it
whoops oh but now but then it just came
back up okay and that's going to show
that right now and i want to and then i
want to move on and tell you about
something there were warrants that were
selectively enforced which is also
terrifying and i before we go to this
clip i want you to understand here the
fbi is not out there to protect you and
it goes back to january 6 2 really
quickly before we go to that clip look
the fbi has not released this footage
they say they lost it
now remember how i said the kyle written
house trial imagine where this kid would
be
if we didn't have all of this footage
yeah yeah right if we didn't have
footage more than you can watch in a
lifetime showing people yelling you know
serial pedophiles yelling that they were
you know f you i'm going to kill you get
his ass hitting him with a skateboard if
he didn't have all that footage and it
was just he said she said this this kid
would fry yeah now we go to the fbi had
this footage which by the way
more that this this trial this case
should have been thrown out okay yeah
now january 6th let's go to that they
want to create that exact scenario with
donald trump what does the fbi want they
want they have warrants for his phone
his texts his emails any communications
that had taken place his computers but
but they're not releasing
hundreds of hours of footage from
january 6th yeah
and we'll go back to that but think
about is it could it be as well because
there you have hundreds of thousands of
people on the capital lawn
and
i'll i'll get to this in a second let's
go to kyle right now i have a theory and
it's entirely an inference but i will uh
make the case for you that um
the fbi has a lot of agents in the field
uh deliberately acting as catalysts for
acts of violence in some cases all right
let's go to this uh cal written house
clip this is new i'm seeing it for the
first time quickly on the record number
one on friday the parties received a
high definition copy of a video
drone footage that we all previously had
lower resolution copies of it's from a
source uh identified as brandon beeman
or urban unaired um urban air something
like that
and i believe there's an agreement that
that's going to be added to our
stipulated list of uh authentic videos
so that we won't need a witness to lay a
foundation of authenticity i want to put
two things
so what is he saying he's basically
saying that are they saying that that
footage was not from an fbi it was from
some they're saying it from an urban air
so somebody had a drone over the right
that's what they initially said it was
from the fbi and maybe separate footage
that the fbi had and lost
that's no no we can go back to the first
day of the trial they said fbi footage
they said right yeah they described it
as fbi footage now they're saying it's
not
yeah think about it dude footage maybe
divided by the dave you remember that
you watched it yeah yeah yeah yeah
footage yeah they did well they could
have just confiscated it
you know like a diary yes
so here's the thing they also asked for
they said if it was a plane for the fbi
they asked for a tail number of it they
they were trying to get identification
on it so it looks like there's two
things happening one the fbi it looks
like did have something in the air
taking footage and also there was
additional footage available that the
fbi either confiscated or took
themselves that was higher quality and
didn't have access to it because they
said they lost it and now i don't
believe it because we've already looked
through uh through trackers and didn't
see uh other flying objects
there's nothing that was registered
small small small drones well you still
have to register those uh with the uh
with the fec i believe if you get a
above a certain yeah if you get above a
certain level and they said that these
footage
well no it says on the footage 8 500
feet right i'm not mistaken does it can
we check that while we're live right now
i think that that requires the one that
we saw certification yeah well they're
saying that one was the fbi that was the
hd one is the one that may not have come
from oh come on oh oh so whatever
no additional the fbi could have done
their own hd stuff i don't believe any
other [ __ ] i'm sorry let me let me tell
you why i don't believe anything it's
radish
not even so the prosecution is acting
really shady too okay let me give you a
couple of examples here detective martin
howard okay he was the detective who's
on this case guy who was a detective for
less than two years keep in mind given
the most important case in kenosha
county of the decade um he had a warrant
for gage crow screwed his phone that's
the guy with the bicep guy yeah the guy
who got shot in the biceps biceps
so he had a warrant for it this is
important the prosecutor thomas binger
instructed
the detective who had a warrant
not
to serve the one so this detective and
then i'm going to tie it back to the fbi
had a warrant for the footage of the guy
who attempted to execute kyle
rittenhouse
didn't serve it
didn't get his footage
here's just so you
don't believe me you don't have to take
my word for it you went in the phone
without a warrant for mr humor correct
we don't need search warrants if they're
deceased that's your opinion correct yes
okay you went and you got a search
warrant
which you drafted and really defiant
meaning you swore to it for mr
groskwitz's phone correct correct and
then it was never executed correct
no because i did not feel
comfortable with my knowledge of marcy's
law and i wanted to err on the side of
caution with that you can get into the
phone other ways correct
which phone are we talking about
biceps guys i see you have consent on
one side or a search warrant on the
other side
and
consent was asked for correct correct it
was turned down correct correct nothing
now to be clear and this is a we uh
we'll have a clip uh or we should have a
clip somewhere we'll put up on the
website all references available at
lateralcredit.com just just so you guys
know um
this detective
had never
not acted on a warrant
based on marsy's law before or since
then this is the only time he's ever
done it
ever
and now well the good thing is the
little [ __ ] with the gun who tried to
execute kylo ren house was live
streaming on facebook before they
removed it but time machine we still
have it so
um let me explain you what marcy's law
is here which is what he used as a
defense for not serving a warrant for
the only time in his career as a
detective marcy's law protects victims
of crimes from searches and seizures so
in order to preserve the and protect
victims rights to justice and due
process throughout the criminal and
juvenile justice process victims shall
be entitled to all the following rights
which shall vest at the time of
victimization privacy to refuse an
interview deposition or other discovery
requests made by the accused or any
person acting on behalf of the accused
meaning if someone rapes you
right if they rape you and there's
evidence that they have raped you they
cannot demand access to all of your hard
drives in front because that's another
way where they can actually hurt the
victim the problem is in this case the
guy was uh had a handgun
crush cruz gage we'll call him gage
because he has he has he has the the
gauges in his ears which is like an
[ __ ] team jersey oh my gosh but did
you catch what he said prior to that
he went and got a
warrant
which means he had to go to a judge
which means the judge had to review the
details of the request and say
yes you can go and get these wouldn't
the judge have taken marsy's law or
marcy's rule whatever it's called into
account yes issuing that parade yeah
seriously i mean he just basically said
i thought it was compelling enough to go
and get the warrant and then i had a
change of heart well here's what's also
here's what's also interesting you said
under marcy's law because he believed
that uh cross crews gage was the victim
yeah
and i guess if anyone is shot if you
want to say that the victim regardless
of whether it's self-defense then let's
at least acknowledge that it would go
both ways here's what's interesting the
kenosha pd reached out to the fbi
to unlock kyle rittenhouse's phone
back in 2020 when you seized mr
rittenhouse's phone
you wanted to get in the phone you
immediately sent it to the fbi so that
it could be
opened or cracked and they told you they
couldn't do that correct correct and
myself and mr rittenhouse found out
about that correct correct and we said
you want to get this phone we'll give
you the code as long as we get a copy of
whatever you take correct correct and
those arrangements were made and his
phone was downward
so there's nothing hidden
correct okay
correct got the cord for the phone yeah
yeah correctly
like that but he's doing a good job all
right so here's what really matters
because they went to the fbi okay the
case here with cal written out the only
case that the left has tried to present
is these other people were acting in
self-defense right right they've even
tried to say well gage the guy who was
shot in the bicep was chasing kyle
rittenhouse because he believed he was
an active shooter going on a rampage
well here's the thing um about that the
warrant shows that after kyle shot
rosenbaum but before the other shootings
kyle told gage so before he was smacked
on the ground with a skateboard before
the kid gage came up with a gun on him
that kyle rittenhouse said i'm going to
call the police so this was on the
warrant request so in other words they
were saying he was going to go commit
more shootings the warrant said actually
there's footage on gage's mr biceps
handgun on his phone that would show
kyle saying
friendly friendly i'm going to call the
police
i'm going to the police sorry i'm going
to the police which make it very very
clear that he was not attempting right
to shoot anybody else um at that time
also gage said get his ass get is it
well here's the thing the warrant which
wasn't served the only warrant in this
case that i know of that was not served
with that evidence
would have that evidence uh if he had
you know procured the footage and i
guess it's lost the time oh no wait uh
the [ __ ] live streamed on facebook
and we have a clip
shots
this is before they hit him with the
skateboard and try to shoot him
get his ass get his ass so doesn't that
change the context they're actually they
beat him with a skateboard and try to
shoot him to stop him from going to the
cops no yeah he said he was going to the
police he was no longer a threat you had
firsthand knowledge of that did he sound
like a threat but he's like i'm going to
the police with his rifle aiming at the
ground exactly if he was there to hunt
gates hell i don't know if you could
have done it then i don't know if you
know this but mass shooters when they
are surrounded by bags of meat
don't tend to go straight to the police
right yeah really yeah i know it's it's
a common misconception
i don't think it's tough i might not be
right on that you know i haven't
committed enough mass shootings in my
day
unbelievable by the way the the crowd
i mean stephen need to get out more yeah
i don't actually do that i'm a hermit so
you all count you're looking to be
specific here a real couch potato when
it comes to mass shootings yeah you know
my dad always said hey if he's if he
keeps sitting on that couch he'll never
kill anybody nope well that's probably a
good thing maybe stay on the couch yeah
i showered with them way too late what
would we be well that's true i was going
to say they're awesome
they were covering some of the police
officers who didn't respond to written
house they were like oh yeah he didn't
look like a threat at all and by the way
there was so much gunfire going on
around us we still thought something was
going down so here's the thing not only
did they talk to the guy and see a guy
running towards the cops and think oh no
he's a mass shooter right that's
obviously a lie there were actually
people firing their guns in the vicinity
and they didn't run to them to try to
stop them no none of them went that way
right that's what the cops testified to
in the trial speaking of gage with the
gauges in his ears he's actually
testifying right now and he just
revealed that he didn't have a or he
didn't have an active permit for the gun
he had wow
yeah let me see that really quickly and
then i want to build the case as to why
the fbi needs to longer exist
did you have a permit to carry a
concealed weapon i did did you kieran
culkin with a beard on august 25th 2020.
it was not
had it expired really it had and you had
not renewed it i had not
then you can't get kyle rittenhouse on a
firearm charge how about that do you
sell fake ecstasy to freshman yes yes
correct
sir did you commit a crime that's
correct that's correct
are you the weird guy who lets teenagers
party at his house yes yes that is also
true uh yes yes how many counts of date
rape four yep uh no your honor i'm sorry
there's six there's two pending yeah
yeah well but one confirmed i mean two
we're asking for it do you keep a
nitrous tank next to your hot tub yes i
do that is that is correct but uh but uh
that's not that's out of context what do
you mean i also keep uh cans of cool
whip yes your honor just to be clear i
keep heads in my freezer as well yes i
don't want i just want to put it on
sometimes i pay i put the fake ecstasy
in the mouth of the head in my freezer
uh using it as a storage unit that is
true i uh i'm sure you've heard of fight
club i have tickle club yes yeah
i'm the only member uh well that's sorry
there's me
and myself mr uh turtan so there's two
severed heads it's just me
but i consider it too i have a big
feather and it tickles your honor uh you
met me at a really strange time also i
collect candelabras
ornate
you didn't ask but i figured i would
assist in the investigation
yeah
are you no well okay
consider yourself lucky because once you
get hooked oh boy oh i've got a guy stop
you're on i'm also a huge brewers fan
yep i uh huge brewers fan and i i uh you
will know if you go through my bank
records that i have gone to see the
creed reunion tour four times
i had to go fifth i stand by nickelback
i uh stand by them
your honor why is he so forthcoming he
won't be charged for any of this no no
no no no
seriously
in other words at this point keep in
mind keep in mind the cal right now is
the only charge that can make stick is
still a broadly written law as far as
underage with a long gun in the state of
wisconsin because kids can go hunting in
other words this guy committed crimes
apparently there were misdemeanors not
felonies but absolutely was illegally
carrying a firearm so yeah
you have to be you have to be consistent
about it in other words the one thing
they have on kyle
they also did and they were pedophiles
and choked their girlfriends and put a
knife to their brother's throat so hey
come on if we're going to go the
character assassination look i don't
think someone should be locked up
forever for not having the proper carry
permit but i do think that you know a
dirt nap for a five-time pedophile is
you know it's not a bad thing okay so
the lead detective this is some other
evidence of corruption here the lead
detective on the case is a benjamin
atramani
atariamian a pteramian i don't know i
don't know i'm sure that's right yeah
the nephew he's the nephew of the
kenosha mayor john
ataremian wait a second hmm now the
kenosha city attorney
ed
anteramian i'm seeing it is the mayor's
cousin huh so you've got
relatives the mayor the lead detective
and the city attorney huh
keep that so there's a there's a motive
to convict kyle and distract from the
failures of the mayor who let the city
burn
keep that in mind for a second that's
weird
three
three enter means and and something
let it be known that kenosha wisconsin
doesn't uh doesn't let whites if that
tire locked if that tire locked fire
spread it would have been an anterimian
genocide
we got to keep us santorinians together
and it would have been uh denied and
there's no room for us in glendale yeah
just call me ants
wear a bunch of ants get it gives her
name yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
be fair we lit half the fires we did
late half the fire and then we laid it
on a little strong when we sang we
didn't start the fire right as we're
starting the fight but that was to throw
them off the scent but looking back i
think it might have actually drawn them
to the scent yeah namely the scent of
tire fires
don't ever put a dumpster on fire so uh
this is something what what is fat sean
penn doing on cnn what is that that
looks like sean penn got stung by 50b it
looks like chris penn you mean
he's dead though
yeah this is this is gonna be a thing
travis scott yeah it's very interesting
a lot of things what is this one yeah
it's a horrible car
people died and someone was allegedly
ejecting them with that uh whatever that
hyper-potent form of fentanyl is and a
stronger version of fentanyl yes
somebody was going around it looked like
stabbing people with a syringe it's
really like a security i think we can
all agree that travis scott is a piece
of garbage well the thing is they will
talk about this at some other time in
the pop culture but this this could be a
big thing this the footage that is
coming out the warnings that he was
issued personally travis scott
i don't care okay so let me just go back
to this the fbi here so you have these
examples of the detective right there
we're talking about relatives right city
attorney the mayor detective they're
related detective went to the fbi to get
kyle's phone decided to not act on a
warrant to get the phone of gage which
we just showed you that footage how that
is kind of pertinent to the case this is
a perfect example of systemic
tar discrimination targeting of
political dissonance you just saw it
with james o'keefe you saw it with the
russia uh collusion hoax now this is
something else that i was bringing up
there's the footage from the fbi it
disappeared in kenosha is there footage
from january 6th
they want every they basically want
access to every single thing trump owns
but they are not releasing the footage
from january 6th
now maybe
maybe that could be because it shows the
police officers there as opposed to this
idea of a planned insurrection
police officers capitol police opening
the doors
[Applause]
police are squabbling with protesters oh
there we go
[Applause]
and they just reached the capitol again
now i want to present to you a theory
that i have as to why they lost the
footage in kenosha
as to why they won't release the footage
at january 6th
um
remember the whitmer kidnapping plot
yeah by the way at one point i think it
was the lansing journal tried to attach
me to it because
we demanded that everyone out there send
out freedom of information requests to
get the actual numbers of you know dead
relatives yeah and senior living homes
so they try to say you're trying to kill
the governor uh no no politically
this is after by the way they said we
had no influence and only a couple
hundred people showed up close to
thousands on the capital lawn so it's
like hey you can't have your cake and
eat it too i guess you can they're
morbidly obese over there
um
yay just down the lawn so here remember
the whitmer kidnapping plot yeah yes a
huge portion
of those involved in the kidnapping plot
were federal agents there were glow
worms who showed up keep in mind
liberty city seven hoax what was that
it was the biggest al qaeda right the
bus
huge portion of them federal agents they
were coercing coercing some of this
information there was an fbi informant
who was the roommate of two of the 911
hijackers right beforehand and i am not
saying of course that this means uh
george bush was sitting behind tower 7
with an acme plunger what i am saying is
that the fbi has continually been
involved when you look at a lot of these
plots
kidnapping
alleged terrorism insurrections
maybe what's going on there in kenosha
you see federal agents so i would tell
you this this is also something that's a
legal defense from the fbi
they've done this in the past where if
footage is to be released to the public
but they say it can compromise
the ability of agents in the field in an
ongoing investigation that they can
refuse to release the footage meaning if
they have someone undercover out there
for example someone who i don't know
makes up the plurality of kidnappers of
governor whitmer they say well hold on
if you have footage of that you can't
why be cool because a good portion of
those agents are ours how many all of
them i'm just i mean almost not split
hairs hey why is there no footage from
january 6th
hundreds of thousands of people only a
couple hundred by the way who clearly
had absolutely no plan
going in they were invited in and then
got unruly and i think those people are
[ __ ] i would i want to want to punch
them in the face myself if they start
you know taking down paintings from the
wall and spray painting and queueing on
shaman i don't think it should be locked
away and denied their rights for
trespassing but it's very clear these
people didn't have a plan for
insurrection they were just like ah let
us in let us all right but you behave oh
they're actually going to let us in okay
well we're not even sure who started
that chant though no right well i'm not
even sure but my point is could it be
could it be could the reason be that
they are not releasing january 6 footage
be the same reason that the footage
in kenosha wisconsin
disappeared
somehow from the fbi in one of the
biggest landmark cases in our country
here right now right basically this may
determine the right to self-defense it
may go up to the supreme court could it
be
that they happen to have instigators on
the ground that they happen to have
agents there on the ground they happen
to have agents there in january 6. just
like they had agents they're connecting
in a plan to kidnap governor whitmer
just like they had agents there in the
the liberty 7 hoax my point is could
that be because that would be a legal
defense to withhold footage
but it is very very suspect when they
are working with local detectives to say
hey get kyle's phone hold on a second
you're
working with that guy to get kyle
rittenhouse's phone the guy's not
serving a warrant
for the phone of the guy who tried to
execute kyle rittenhouse and by the way
fbi you have footage that you've lost
and you raided james o'keefe's house
nothing with donald trump's with a
sitting president's tax returns
i don't know i don't know if it's just
me but i i am beyond having any trust in
the fbi and here's really what it comes
down to maybe there are some good people
at the fbi however you have no trust to
left with the american people so you
can't be you can't even function at
serving your duties it's time to disband
the fbi and create something in its
place something with something with
something similar to term limits for
agents right well so with the agents
it's like guys it's time to stand up and
and make sure your voices are heard if
you're a good agent there and you want
to serve this country which i think the
vast majority of on-the-ground boots in
the fbi do want to do it's the career
pencil pushers like you're talking about
the desk jockeys or the people that are
appointed politically when your
government asks you to do something
that's illegal don't do it yeah right or
or or at least enforce the laws equally
we brought up the dinesh d'souza uh rose
dinesh d'souza did time in prison for
donating too much to a campaign of a
friend who got lost right he's the only
person to do time in prison then wasn't
it roseanne who uh not roseanne but uh
who who's the lady who donated in
california donated
said the same thing it's not roseanne
what's the leftist rosary rosie rosie
right that heinous fat prick yeah so
rosie o'donnell did the same thing that
dinesh d'souza did only worse gave more
money and nothing and paintings at all
well that's yeah that's true but they
wanted the paintings she did paintings
of trump for real yeah i know yeah yeah
yeah yeah
really like a jackson j edgar hoover
would be clutching his pearls if he were
around today well it was just it was
just really just her hand and some
feathers did you see that for a turkey
turkey she's insane it's a butterball
she there has to be an investigation
into this by the way
into rosie o'donnell no no no no no no
it has to be an investigation into why
they're rating project veritas employees
and former employees trying to who's
gonna investigate him
it's a double investment that's my point
is who's going who investigates the
investigation congress yeah good luck
with that no i'm saying if look if 2022
if you ever needed a reason to get out
and make sure that 2022 went our way
like stuff like this scares the hell out
of you because this is a step towards a
police state and no the police state
doesn't happen because of your life i
will say it
i will say it here on this show okay and
by the way you guys can comment below uh
and you can smash that like button if
you're watching on on youtube
um
anyone who comes on this show and we
know that well it's very likely that
we'll have some of the presidential
candidates for the next election on this
show
we've gotten we get requests pretty
regularly for politicians to be on the
show uh we have a select few on this
show i will not support anyone who does
not have a plan in place to deal with
our intelligence agencies
not well some of them are good and
either disband or a very very concrete
plan
because i fully expect this to get worse
and by the way i fully expect for them
to come out come after us at some point
for jokes you don't think the fbi is
working
with big tech companies
yeah which brings me to my next point
here
no seriously this is a horrifying this
is um last week our coverage and i say
this that you don't think they're
working with big tech companies our
coverage of the kyle rittenhouse trial
on youtube earned an age restriction you
know right here yeah it says it's age
restricted and this is due to showing
clips
uh allegedly from the i don't know
because they never answer you mean clips
that everybody else yes well that's the
same those clips yeah those clips that
we just shot
now keep in mind now people said why
don't you create your own youtube sure
fine and we are on rumble just to be
clear the issue here and i don't even
have an issue with age restricting
content
um i have an issue with age restricting
the exact same content
with the exclusive difference being
a political point of view now i know
there are a lot of people who are out
there who love to be professional
martyrs on the right and claim so
youtube can do whatever it wants but you
would have to age restricts the content
from and we'll have all the references
available later with crowder at least
start with the exact same footage that
is still available unrestricted right
now
new york times youtube channel
ridden house shoots him in the chest
here is gage gross kroitz with his gun
draw i need a [ __ ] mannequin
and fell to the ground that's actually
worse than the footage without
the blood and aiming his rifle at the
men pursuing him
two men were laying on the ground one of
them was not moving
he falls and fires again killing huber
and gross kroitz in the shoulder
so we just gave you four examples new
york times washington post nbc affiliate
and an abc affiliate same footage not
age restricted worse footage yeah worse
footage and by the way that can cut into
30 40 percent of your views and a huge
portion of our content is restricted
it's just a soft subtle way of saying i
don't want anybody else to see this
hold on age restriction and i thought
about it was like oh well nobody under
under the age of 18. it's not just that
i think you were saying you actually
have to be logged in yeah to be logged
in verify your age and you can't cast it
to your television or watch it typically
in television apps wow okay so it's a
little bit more than just yeah it's a
little bit more than that it's youtube
pulling the old scrooge and they could
look they can do what they want if they
apply it equally
so youtube we're looking at you right
now you better age i mean it's not like
it's gonna affect them because no one
really watches them but new york times
washington post the nbc affiliate the
abc affiliate you know what we can find
20 more for you
if i have no problem with you age
restricting it as long as you age
restrict it honestly why well this is
also why we don't whitewash what joseph
rosenbaum said because they do on new
york times they do it on washington post
where they say kyle rittenhouse murdered
and then they say where uh the uh
the
gage character allegedly had a gun no no
it's on tape
so they can paint it a certain way with
a political bent and we're not able to
respond to it on equal footing because
it's age restricted i just want the
rules to be applied equally you've
demonetized me got it you've hard struck
the channel for [ __ ] uh guideline
violations never explained what they
were got it you've age restricted
content even though it's not age
restricted on any other left-leaning
channel got it just apply it equally
just like the fbi
apply it equally if you want all of
donald trump's texts phone calls
communications computers
release the january 6 footage how about
that if you're going to have warrants
served for kyle rittenhouse and
potentially his parents next of kin all
of these peop
just released the drone footage or the
fbi plane footage that you have you
can't just say oh it disappeared if
you're going to raid the home
of matthew modine look like james
o'keefe
you have to raid the offices of the new
york times or washington post for
procuring the tax returns which is
actually illegal of a sitting president
i am not saying that they can't do this
i i would rather they didn't
what i am saying is they cannot apply
the law selectively you do not live in a
free country if you have a country with
laws the rule of law doesn't mean
anything
if the law is only applied to political
dissidence that is fascism but i'm
speaking of of today's far left so i
repeat myself all right we are going to
go uh hit the share button if you want
to hit the like button comment uh if
you're on rumble thank you very much
youtube we're gonna play actually
because of this
a game age restricted or not on mug club
we could never do this on youtube but
what's age restricted
might surprise you not the gay porn